>> Greg: HE'S GOT A KNACK FOR
BRINGING BARS AND RESTAURANTS
BACK.
WITH COVID RESTRICTIONS WAIVED,
CAN THEY BE SAVED?
FOR THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF,
THE U.S. BAR AND RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN HIT WITH ONE
OF THE MOST CHALLENGING
ECONOMIES EVER.
REPORTING 110,000 RESTAURANTS
CLOSED TEMPORARILY OR FOREVER IN
2020.
HOW'S IT GOING TO LOOK LIKE POST
PANDEMIC?
MOST OF THE GREAT SHOW BAR
RESCUE, WHICH AIRS ITS 200TH
EPISODE THIS SUNDAY.
I'VE SEEN ALL OF THEM ON THE
PARAMOUNT NETWORK.
JOHN, I'M NOT LYING.
CYRUS AND I WERE BOTH TALKING
ABOUT IT LIKE WE BINGE WATCHED
YOUR SHOW.
USUALLY ON SUNDAYS WITH A
HANGOVER, YOU WILL BE CRADLING
ME IN HIS ARMS, ANYWAY -- I'VE
GOT A QUESTION FOR YOU.
BETWEEN THOSE MOMENTS WHEN YOU
ARE YELLING AT SOMEONE, DO YOU
EVER FEEL COMPELLED TO WINK AT
THEM SO THEY DON'T BREAK DOWN IN
TEARS?
>> I PROBABLY HAVE DONE THAT
ONCE OR TWICE, I MUST SAY.
A LITTLE PAT ON THE BACK AS I
WALK BY OR SOMETHING.
THAT WINK CAN BRING THEM BACK,
IF YOU KNOW IT I MEAN?
>> YOU KNOW WHO I REALLY HATED
THAT I STILL REMEMBER THE GUY,
IS THE GUY WHO WANTED TO OPEN A
COMEDY CLUB IN ARIZONA.
DO YOU REMEMBER HIM?
>> YES, HE WAS THE ONE THAT SAID
COMEDY DOESN'T NEED TO BE FUNNY.
>> YES!
AND I PROVED HIM RIGHT.
>> THE NAME OF THE EPISODE WAS
THE [BLEEP] SAGA.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU WALKED INTO HIS
COMEDY CLUB, IT SMELLED LIKE
CHARD MEAT.
>> Greg: HE TOOK HIS PARENTS
MONEY BECAUSE HE COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND -- HE BOUGHT A COMEDY
CLUB SO WE COULD ON THE CLUB AND
HANG OUT THERE AND PRETEND HE
WAS A COMEDIAN.
IT'S ONE OF MY FAVORITE
EPISODES.
BUT I DIGRESS, HOW DO YOU SEE
THE COMING YEAR FOR BARS AND
RESTAURANTS?
>> BOOM TOWN.
EVEN NEW YORK, L.A., I'M HERE IN
VEGAS.
VEGAS WAS SOLD OUT LAST WEEK IN.
SO WE ARE REALLY COMING BACK.
WHEN YOU SPEAK TO EVERY
RESTAURANT OWNER, THE PEOPLE ARE
COMING BACK.
BUT WE HAVE TWO PROBLEMS.
BOTH GOVERNMENT PAUSES.
THE ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS.
THINK ABOUT THIS, AND LARRY
DOES, IF IT'S A TWO HOUSEHOLD
PERSON -- THEY ARE MAKING
HUNDRED DOLLARS EACH AND
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS, THAT'S
ABOUT $83,000 A YEAR.
MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD THEN ONLY COMES
TO 67,000 A YEAR.
HE COULD STAY HOME AND ACCEDE TO
MEDIUM INCOME, BUT RIGHT NOW THE
GOVERNMENT IS FRONTING US FROM
GETTING OUR EMPLOYEES BACK.
RESTAURANTS ARE OPEN TWO DAYS
RATHER THAN SEVEN DAYS, IT'S
KILLING US.
THE OTHER THINGS THAT KILLING
US -- YOU KNOW HOW THOSE LITTLE
KETCHUP PACKETS THAT WE HAVE?
THOSE USED TO COST $0.07.
THEY WENT UP TO $0.11.
THEN $0.30.
NOW IT IS $0.40 FOR KETCHUP
PACKETS.
NOW I BLAME THAT ON THE
GOVERNMENT TOO.
YOU KNOW WHY?
CATCH UP.
HE'S GOT TO HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YES, YES!
>> Greg: HE'S DUMPING ALL OF
IT OFF AS HE OUGHT TO KEEP THE
PRICES UP.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU DON'T LIKE
SOMEBODY COME UP WITH THE
KETCHUP PACKETS UNDER THE
WINDSHIELD WIPER.
>> I THINK IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
UNDER THE TOILET BOWL.
>> Greg: YES.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE BARS IN
SAN FRANCISCO -- I'M A TIKI BAR
FREAK.
MY FAVORITE IS OUT IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S STILL NOT OPEN.
HOW MANY PLACES JUST AREN'T
GOING TO OPEN?
>> A WHOLE BUNCH, GREG.
THE FACT WAS I WAS MAKING FUN
WITH THE KETCHUP PACKETS, BUT
MEAT IS TWICE THE PRICE.
RESTAURANTS CAN'T RAISE THEIR
PRICES TO ADJUST TO THAT.
THEY ARE LOSING MONEY.
WE ARE GOING TO LOSE ABOUT 20%
OF THE RESTAURANT AND BAR IS
ONCE WE ARE DONE.
>> HOW CAN THE PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THE SITUATION -- OBVIOUSLY MY
SOLUTION IS ALWAYS TO DRINK
HEAVILY AND OVER TIP AND IT BE
THROWN OUT.
SHOULD EVERYBODY?
>> PART OF ME?
>> PERFECT CUSTOMER.
>> Greg: YES.
>> YOU KNOW, GREG, WE HAVE TO BE
CONSCIOUS OF COMMUNITIES.
AND IT'S NOT JUST BARS AND
RESTAURANTS.
AT SALONS AND OTHER BUSINESSES
AS WELL.
WE HAVE TO KEEP OUR MONEY LOCAL.
IF WE DON'T KEEP OUR MONEY
LOCAL, THESE LOCAL BUSINESSES
ARE GOING TO DISAPPEAR.
THEY ARE THE CHARACTER OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
SO MY ADVICE IS KEEPING UP AND
BE PREPARED.
PRICES ARE GOING TO INCREASE.
IT ISN'T THE RESTAURANT'S
CHOICE, BUT THEY ARE GOING TO GO
UP BIG TIME.
I BLAME IT ON JOHN KERRY.
>> Greg: I DO TOO.
EVERYBODY WATCH, IT'S ON
PARAMOUNT, HE'S G